[Music]
a c b I don't have a grade for him it's
so bad it's beyond F he get a Dem minus
give him a be but uh he can do better uh
it should be a better solution than the
one they using cuz evidentally it's not
working that situation is completely
ridiculous and out of hand everybody and
their cousin and their great
grandmothers thousands of people come in
through the water every day you know why
don't we just move to Mexico or down in
South America because before it's all
over with they be more taking over the
United States than uh the people that
was born or rais raised or been here for
Generations immigration is obviously a
very large issue that's something that
we're you know we got to figure that out
we got to figure out the southern the
the southern border we see the
immigration crisis seeing the sanctuary
cities taking in people so I I do see
and know it's an issue uh especially for
these big cities like DC New York
Chicago that are you know taking in you
know taking in immigrants and you know
the Mayors are coming out saying we
don't have enough space so it's a huge
issue one of the top things under the
ballot in 24 so yeah they got to figure
that out he's trying but I think there's
more that can be done
there's always more that can be done
youve done a pretty good job he's got
the border so the border patrols
catching everybody that they can and uh
but they're being inundated the Congress
is withholding funds is pretty hard to
do given that the problem is so huge I
think he's doing his best they get a lot
of things that we as born Americans here
do not get can't get won't get there's
so much red tape with us but they allow
other people in the country which I
don't I don't have a problem with that
but I think every like again everyone
should be treated the same basically the
same way it's a
travesty uh there seems to be no um
remedy um at all uh I just hope the next
Administration that comes in whether
it's Democratic or republican can um
take care of this problem I feel bad for
the folks down on the border of Mexico
uh what's going on when people come into
their property unw warranted I don't
understand how that can happen it's a
difficult problem as an immigrant I know
it's a difficult problem I mean you
cannot just turn back everybody you know
but uh this is getting out of hand I
understand and
uh must some some Rule and some limit
must be must be
set